man's pleasure for me to introduce the
speaker on our
bootcamp lectures on on satisfiability
solving
uh armin biera and the only thing i'm
slightly worried about is that the
presentation of armin will take up like
all the available time because there's
so much to say
so i'll try to keep it somewhat brief so
armin is at the johannes kepler
university in indians austria
before that he was at eth has been in
industry
in electronic design automation and
he has also been with
[Applause]
[Music]
um sorry about that
um it was a pothole kind of on the
clocks at cmu
i got his phd from university of
karlsruhe
he's famous for his work in applied
formal methods
in particular former verification of
hardware uh
um famer famous for his contributions to
to boundless model checking to
satisfyability solving
for solving quantified boolean formulas
and satisfiability modulo theory
has been taken part in numerous
competitions
uh more medals than i can count i think
it says cine
cd 37 gold medals 67 in total
awards the ibm faculty award a lot of
influential paper test of time awards
from
takas hbc
um from etaps also the cab award
the ichikai j-a-a-r award
and has worked as an editor of the
handbook of satisfiability
where we just the second edition is just
out has been
chair and vice chair of the sat
association and
although the sat community is a very
competitive community
of course and armin doesn't always win
the sad competition i think it's
undisputed that he's considered to be
the
leading authority on all things related
to sat and so when
in the organizing committee we thought
about who might give a tutorial on sat
it was a very natural name to think
about and and
we're very happy to have army here and
hope that he will explain
all the secrets of that to us so without
further ado please army
well thank you very much so uh let me
start sharing my screen again
um all right
i hope you can see this uh otherwise
please uh
tell me so uh it's it's it's actually um
difficult to uh to give this uh just a
second i need to
also see myself for a second um
to give such tutorials i usually give
them actually once a year or a couple of
times a year so last
fall i actually gave two of these and so
i was really sort of like
um yeah i said yes when when the
organizers asked me to to give a
tutorial here uh but then i overlooked
that they wanted to have a video so i
prepared a video last week and
i got so hooked up to this video that
it's actually became four and a half
hours so if you didn't have a chance to
look at it
you're you're welcome to and now of
course like i have a two hours talk and
and should assume you all watch these
four and a half hours which of course
i guess nobody did at least not in slow
motion so so what should i do
anyhow so the other problem with such a
talk is
that like 10 years ago when i gave such
a talk like nobody
really knew about cdcl and nowadays of
course if i start talking and explaining
cd0 like
people get bored and then only after 45
minutes
into the talk um uh people get
interested so i'm really not sure like
uh what to say here but let me just
um explain what i want to do so i took
a talk from from um
last december actually which i gave at
the sardis mt school in
in in india which um actually also like
all together was i think three hours
and and cut it down and remove those
parts which you were supposed to watch
in the video
already so the video has a different
style so it's like blackboard
and and code and um i'm going to
um try to do the same now
but it's of course like maybe less
organized and and it's also on purpose
less organized so so i had this idea
and so i have this like four and a half
hours of video even though there's some
parts missing which which i want to
touch now um
um you were supposed to watch the more
students or
like if you're interested awards were
supposed to dodge watch them and then if
if something is um unclear then let's
let's talk about this now so i'm very
happy if you
interrupt me in any time
and i will answer your questions i guess
i will need to repeat
questions right so i hope this is
working somehow because we have this
webinar thing
anyhow um so
well this is the slide i gave to my dean
once in 2015
actually so what i'm doing so but jacob
already said about this
so let me just like show you maybe this
plot here
so this is a another cactus plot for
those of you who have followed the sat
community so this is a cumulative
distribution function
um on the uh the
vertical and axis here you you see the
number of solved instances over the time
so in 5 000 seconds you see like
the winner of of last year's competition
which is mice over kisad actually sold
250 out of these 400 benchmarks in that
competition
and then eight each of these lines here
is actually
um um a solver winning a competition
over the years
uh so actually starting with the 2002
where we still have sort of records like
the well competition actually in 1994
but we don't really have any source code
of these sources
so so i took all these solvers uh which
were uh presented
um which were winning those competition
and
um kind of ported them to new compilers
so this was
actually an effort because some of them
were were kind of uh
produced in the age of 32-bit machines
uh but i got that working and it's also
sound like
at least there were no discrepancies in
all these runs
and then i was running all of them like
the old uh ported source cc
source for the class plus code on the
new cluster so this is all in the same
machine
and and then you see like sort of mice
over from 90f
from 2002 lima just barely solved the 52
or so uh benchmarks
uh while the uh sort of newest silver
solves like five times more
and and you also see a considerable
improvement over the years
and you might also wonder why is there
such a big gap
actually turns out that three solvers
jumped that high from like 2019
i think i think you see my mouse pointer
right from 2019 here
maple version from 2019 uh to uh 2020
uh but i i don't show them here so this
is really only sort of the top the the
fastest solver over these years
usually in the sub competition they're
like 50 participants of course this this
would not fit
fit on the slide okay and
uh yeah in 2003 for instance we were
missing something
uh which is siege and and so i only have
this berkman there
anyhow so there was a big improvement i
posted this on on twitter and maybe some
of you saw that
and i was kind of um make quite around
this this tweet
and um yes so lots of likes and retweets
and then people even from the machine
learning community came and gave
comments so they want to know how many
how many variables we can solve and and
so i plotted this
variable distribution plot which shows
that in the competition there were like
quite some instances so this is i guess
the median is around hundred thousand
uh variables uh sorry hundred thousand
clauses and
and here's probably like 10 000
variables
but it goes up to sort of like a
multi-million
clauses and and and variables
and uh this is related maybe to the the
other thing which you see here on the
right so this is from a
github issue tracking from our
smt solo boo lecture and there were some
colleagues
using this uh uh inside of esbmc which
is about
model checker from from oxford and they
applied this to
deep neural networks uh like uh
they use the smt syllabu lecture and
deep neural web verification and then
they
uh they they hit this back i i hope you
can read it uh if zoom
quality allows so this is it says
internal error in
lgl we see more than like 140
134 million variables this is exactly 2
to the power
27 and then the question was can you do
anything about it and actually well this
was
um um an issue with the sat silver
because that south server which is
actually here this lingering here which
is also my soft solver for instance
linkedin 2014 um is um
only always restricted to two to the
power of 27
um um so this is like 27 million
variables
uh and they really run these large
instances and
i assume they have a machine return on
56
gigabyte memory because otherwise uh
linguine would not have that limit
so what's really interesting about that
is that it's really um
the case now that we're hitting inside
solving
the limit of 32 bit right so people are
using
set servers for things with more than
say 2 billion variables which is
quite quite amazing i think and
currently i don't have a satsa which
supports 64-bit variable agencies but
but i assume
before i retire this will be necessary
all right um so beside that of course
like jacob already said we have been
doing this handbook so this is the one
from 2009
and uh this is um together with marian
hoyland hans von maran and toby walsh
and that's the old um uh chapter here
actually the old chapters plural and we
have like 29
and and maybe the next thing i can brag
about
is this this thing in 2012 so this is
trento
and you see here a couple of people i'm
not sure like uh people are in the
audience also
so this is mariah in the front john
franco roberto sebastiani and this is
a donald truth uh who was visiting the
sat community back then in trento
me uh then it's like all the horse cars
since
and and so we were really like uh
very happy that uh smooth wanted to
learn about sad solving and
and he also sent me an email and also
other people
and i got like a request for 48
questions from my sides of the pixar
because
back then and and then he actually came
to linz
where he gave a talk and wanted to to
discuss for a week
um how cdcs sewing is working so again
this was in
in in 2013 and
uh uh yeah he also played the anton
puchner origin
this was uh quite quite uh quite amazing
and
then um in 2015 um just around christmas
he uh published this book i think i have
a version here so
it's the size i hope you can see this
and it's it's actually a very small
section if you go
uh inside so this is from the pdf you
see this is section 7.2.2.2
it has a around like 300 pages
and and well uh it's really amazing like
he went through the history in in
collected things
and also programmed actually assess over
now um what happened since then in the
field uh some of you know
and it was mentioned before is we we
have been um
uh busy uh trying to get a new um
or editing a new volume a new um
edition of the handbook and it's really
now
uh i haven't seen a physical copy yet
but at least i saw some virtual copies
it's really in the print
and uh these are new chapters seven new
chapters one
improved complexity which is probably
mostly related to this uh
seminar it's it's also the biggest new
chapter in more than 100 pages
we finally put a pre-processing chapter
in it because like 2009 is
was not ready yet we didn't know much
too enough about pre-processing
then also holger house uh and and his
colleagues
uh contributed a chapter which they
promised but didn't want to do in 2009
then wrote the chapter on this proof of
unsatisfiability
and then we have two chapters which have
a similar flavor since these 10
uh since 10 years there was actually
huge progress in maxsat and also in qpf
solving
and while the original um contributors
to the original chapters in the handbook
kind of um stopped working on this topic
so there were new
techniques invented and these people
here were um
writing new chapters because of that and
and this is also very like a sort of
up-to-date
um version of qbf and markzware and last
but not least something we've seen
um and and where there will be a talk uh
also on on
on friday is this approximate model
counting there was already approximate
model counting in the handbook but
this one is a precise one and um
but we got also like three quotes from
doing award winners which you probably
have seen now already by
now and here's the flyer in case you
haven't seen the flyer so it's
out you can buy it and order it you
cannot really buy it i think
and yeah it's two volumes now because
it's getting too thick
and maybe i should show you if this is
the first one so
we don't have the second one
all right um so but now maybe technical
so what what is practical start solving
so this talk
is called satsoi and i usually
have these uh sort of like three things
and often i only give a talk on one
and um in essence uh in the video
which i taped on on friday and which you
should find on the
on the web um you i talk about encoding
and search so today
i'll uh repeat a little bit from this
encoding search my hope is that
that you will ask questions and then
i'll can
re like deepen some of these things i
didn't explain
in that video but i will also want to
talk about proofs
sort of more from the practical side and
also so show some code
just um barely an hour ago i was able to
fix this
sash uh sass over which which i
implemented for
for this seminar to also produce proof
and i want to show you this
all right uh this was a 18
transformation i don't want to say much
more about it so
this is now for um again this
distributivity law i said in the in the
in the video but to have everybody um uh
on the same page right so we're having
circuits in general and we introduce
internal signals these x
u v w and y and then we can compare
whether two outputs are different this
is an x or gate and then
this circuit produces a one if and only
if
you can make this this pink and this
yellow circuit different
with the setting values to abc and
because this distributivity law holds
this is not possible and now how do we
get this to sat well you introduced it
with local constraints
and this part is is really sort of
amazing when i first
first learned about it this was in 98
um you first thought like when you do
assad you always have to sort of like
get things into a negation normal form
and this will be exponential but
um this satin uh transformation is
is kind of one of the secrets why start
solving actually took over took off
and and can really scale so because this
this operation
is linear in the size of the input and
it extends actually to other domains so
if you if you want to model a c
program instead of such a circuit you
would do the same thing for each
variable you would introduce such a
local constraint
like this variable is maybe computed by
by the program and and then this is not
an
n but maybe an addition or something
else you could do with the
with two variables and uh and the same
principle applies you just take sort of
these local constraints and you
you conjunct all these constraints
because they then encode the semantics
of the execution
okay and then there's a step where you
take sort of these local constraints you
need to get them into c nav and i i'll
show this here but
this is like many ways of doing this uh
this is kind of a more like manual uh
way way of doing it uh and then you can
do it for many
different operators so you can do it for
negation disjunction conjunction
equivalence and so on and then already
in the video i showed
how how you would do this maybe for like
higher level um
operations like addition here for big
edition
and this is in essence just amounts to
sort of like um sort of like
implementing hardware for doing this
operation
but i i assume everybody uh knows that
so so
this this i didn't discuss in the video
which i think is still like from a
kind of engineering perspective um very
important is
like um well um the input where you sort
of formulate something like in this case
it's
not even your neural network or like a
beat vectors no it's like sort of the
input formula uh format of of our smt
server
and and then in order to get this to to
to start you need like lots of steps
uh and and um yeah so there's like lots
of
rewriting optimization going on and
in particular um sometimes you need to
go back so you learn maybe a unit here
in the south server and you really need
to go down back to the very beginning
which we might trigger things here and
so on so software engine wise
is not as simple as as we described so
there's lots of layers
and and this is also um already like uh
pretty
um uh pretty complex
okay then the other thing i mentioned
already is that there you're having um
like multiple um representations and
on the sort of modeling side this is the
first bullet
you're having an application level then
we can do bit vectors with this
application
level so we can for instance use bit
vectors to describe the operations of
this neural network
then we take bit vectors turn them into
something which is called aig so i'll
show that in a minute
and then from there you would go to cnf
and then all these levels and all these
steps three steps you would do
optimizations and then there's also like
um this issue with logical constraints
which which
are kind of not really formulating
execution of a real machine
and there the encoding needs more sort
of insights like fixed points
is is is usually the the the keyword
or um yeah um um cardinality constraints
which we'll hear about tomorrow
there are also issues on on how to
encode them
um maybe you haven't seen aig's um they
were actually in
invented in in berkeley i mean like at
least like
uh there they became very famous in the
in the
around the tool abc by berkeley
university and um
yeah so you can think of this is a very
simple circuit where you only have and
gates these are these big circles and
these dots here are negations
and the reason we like this in practice
is because
well all your errors will just work with
this sort of very basic logic
um functions and uh yeah of course you
can represent everything with it
so the bitter the the four bit adder we
discussed is this one here to the left
and of course if you want to do eight
bit addition so it down here you see the
inputs you get like a twice as big one
you can do um 128 bit actually doing
this later
in the demo and um
and so on and um
this is a bit vector shifted by um
for shifts right this is a bearer
shifter so the width of this thing is
the
the size of the bit vector and the
height is logarithmic in the
in the size and sort of the
the simplest implementation would be
quadratic but like with this sort of
shifting approach um you get this to n
log
n um even though here i i don't know
whether you can see these these guys are
those with the large fan out these are
the inputs of the shift
uh this you have four right because you
should to shift the 64 bit vectors you
need four bits to
um for the shift uh and these
um uh have really high uh fan out and
are used
quite often anyhow what's that
well listen this is an a multiplier like
an eight bit by eight bit multiplier and
multipliers are quadratic in in size so
if you're
really encode sort of like one assembly
instruction in which you're having
multiplying two numbers both 32-bit you
get
actually like a quadratic um bdd so
actually
sorry not bdd aig and this aig is
is around like 2 000 nodes uh so this is
for eight times eight so it grows like
much more than
then uh like this n log n thing we solve
for the better shifter
okay then uh beside this encoding let's
get closer to the
um to the the sat solving um
um one thing which
is um very um
very important of course is that you're
using these sat solvers through
through through an api through sort of
as
a library and this is very common in
many applications
and um there's like
um
one sort of like um important sort of
trick and that's this uh
assumption trick here which i don't have
complete
fully time to explain so so so the basic
idea is you want to have in a sad silver
um like a library where you can sort of
query these um
this satsa like an oracle right uh and
um the formula you you're occurring
is actually related to previous formulas
so you sort of have an incremental
problem and the
um from what what's typical is that
you're sort of
adding new constraints however um this
would only allow a kind of
sat query style while in practice you
often want to do
an answer so a good example is about a
model checking you might have heard
about sort of you start by
by checking the safety property at the
initial state
and then if it cannot be violated you
increase the time by one and then you're
checking the safety
property at the second state and so on
okay and every time you add this
transition relation
and ask is it possible to violate this
this property at this new time frame
and uh for that you kind of need to sort
of tell the cell so
yes i'm interested in sort of this
unrolling of this circuit
so it's very similar to sort of the
proof that uh that
that satsat uh can uh can simulate
um uh or assad can simulate um the
execution of the turing machine
polynomially right
because uh but but you kind of want to
say that uh okay but now i'm assuming
that this
this um a time step two for instance
this this uh
this uh uh this property is violated and
and then i'm adding here this time frame
like one more execution
uh of the of the machine and then asking
again is it now after one time step
satisfiable so you need to have a
mechanism which which
uh asks a query under assumptions the
assumption in this case would be that
the property is violated
um at the certain uh time step
and this has been sort of more formally
described and we're having their
um like um a formal um
interface it's called ipas here and i'll
i'll just show you this
kind of people call it the model of the
api of the application programmatic
interface
sort of the header file of the library
and
um what you see here is this kind of
this the state
uh this the sad silver can be in and of
course like initially you started with
an unknown state
and and then you can um add um uh things
and what you can add is uh clauses
but you can also assume certain things
like our
assumption that the bad state is reached
like the the death state which violates
the property
um and then after you're done adding
your constraint you can
start solving and you're going to the
solving state
and then from there on you could um of
course like the silver then does it it's
his thing and then
it can internally this is the dashed
line here either
figure out the the formula is uh
satisfiable or figured out it's
unsatisfiable
and then in both cases so that's why i
like this picture there's like a
symmetric
query possible so you can ask in the
satisfiable case for a model for
satisfying assignment
like value means like get me at the
value of one variable okay
actually in the interface it's the
values of literals
and down here in the unsat
well you can say what about these
assumptions were they all necessary to
derive
unsat please tell me whether you use the
particular assumption the derived answer
so this is not
precise so it might tell you
okay a variable like an assumption was
necessary to derive answers but it's not
strictly logically necessary it's just
like that the solver
used it but of course you get so this
failed here
is kind of an over approximation with
that you're getting coarse
and like unsatisfiable subsets of the
assumptions
which then can be used for many
applications it's kind of one of the
core technologies also to
to implement um car based um
max at solvers and and in many
applications
this is a very important part anyhow
like if
you now um kind of stopped investigating
the model or you you
you look through the failing assumptions
and you
want to go back and add new constraints
then sort of like the
the current incremental um solving is
over and you can add new constraints and
so on
whereas like if the so if you ever add
an empty clause here this thing remains
unset forever
okay this is then the the interface in c
but like if you're not a c person this
will not help you much
um and and therefore i want to go much
into this
but now maybe to to everything but but
probably
i don't know how it works but if there
are questions now
maybe would be a good time but i kind of
even we have a question now i think
let's see
uh so
robert robert is asking if there is an
equivalent of a reptile
a read evaluate print loop for any of
the modern sat solvers i've looked
around in the past but i couldn't really
find one this is what i've always wanted
in order to play around with one really
interactively
and what like can you elaborate on this
one
repeat the question so something ah
okay i think he's looking for let's see
something where you can repeatedly
choose
which variable to branch on next and
then have the solver pause so really
really controlled very good very good
point this this is a very
requested features which uh i hope have
only in in lingering but lots of people
i'm not sure there's some in the
audience here but ask me to put this
into category and keysight it's actually
also a very important feature
for kind of smt of solving and that's
also one of the main reason why people
actually in this smt servers well maybe
except for bulactor
really rely on old versions of of sat
solvers because they hacked this
so what you really do is you're
providing um something
which is called kind of implied and
then you're kind of guiding the the the
the smt silver
like by by may sort of really choosing
the decisions what to do next
and then let's sorry not the s p so the
sats over and then do the propagations
and then of course like um yes we also
use this
in once actually i have uh some uh
some application uh ready for the demo
but i don't have that implemented like
for comp it's called combinatorical
testing
where you can also make use of that so
uh for instance the python interface by
by schwa and others is
is actually uses this as it has a kind
of
abstraction of the set so we're doing
that because that's uh
important feature in maxsat solvers so
yes so this is
so existing and uh heavily used in many
applications
so but if i understand the the seer uh
uh like api correctly there you can you
can give the solver
your assumptions but then you let it
just so
so yeah and it will only return once
it's find saturn
so the the reason why um so so this um
ip this design of this ips uh
sir interface was in such a way that
that is as simple as possible and
semantics are completely clear right so
if you go back to this picture
this is even here you see i didn't talk
about fine points so for instance the
fine point here is that
you will forget assumptions when you go
back to um
the next um unknown state and things
like that so even the simple
model you see here has all intricate
semantics now as soon as you add more
complicated um
api functions like the one we just
discussed so actually
in in lingling i call this one's implied
rate so you can sort of like
imply it get implied literals and also
pick the decision
then uh semantics gets really tricky and
then if you do a competition on that so
we're doing a competition with this
thing people disagree on semantics
and that's why we didn't add this the
only thing which i didn't talk about
which was added is this interrupted here
because that is very useful for parallel
sat sewing so you can sort of interrupt
the sats over in the middle of solving
if you find like another solver like
running the parallel thread is
is the reason why we don't have it in it
is because
uh like it's likely really reluctant to
add
like a complex or more complex
functions to it and it will no doubt
make you happy to
to know that robert is asking for for
even more so
and i think he has a good point like
coming from the theory side um
so i'm quoting right now it would be a
dream to be able to choose
uh like decisions and maybe also to
govern
like in fine detail whether the solver
is allowed to propagate or not and when
it reaches a conflict like maybe it
knows several conflict clauses
i get to choose which one it should do
the conflict analysis on
something like that yeah but but this is
so
yeah i mean like in smt servers people
do these things all the time of course
right
and uh but of course the heck is sets
over right
that's what was my argument so it's like
not easy to do this sort of like in a
sort of like nice beautiful
uh generic way um um so i fear like
if you want to play with that you
probably want to hack the sets over but
like
the sad silver i presented this hatch is
maybe a good starting point for doing
that
of course like i'm also happy to help
here if if there's some need for
for doing things like that but what
you're saying is that if you just take
like a standard sat solver then
then going that deep inside it it can
actually get pretty messy and it's not
even
clear that you can like do like cleanly
do a unit propagation by unit
propagation say
yeah so you will break of course in
variances like all these sat solvers
have
um sort of built in um like assumptions
which
break if you use them in a in a in a
different way
and then then of course like settle was
used for different purposes and then
like if you use it for an smt so great
knight needs to have like certain things
if you use it for hot verification needs
certain things if you
you use it as a as a back end for a mug
satsang which has to be completely
different
and then of course like what people do
in practice like in in sort of in
in applications um either invent
something around the satsu which is also
happening quite often or they hack the
sauce over themselves
so practice has a question
what is an example of a situation where
you would want to add assumptions
from the sat state in the ipaser model
oh this is the very s like it's called
um like
for instance you want to um uh find
um um
a mac that you want to solve max that
you can of course start off sort of with
the local search and find the satisfying
assignment right like any optimization
but then you haven't found the minimum
yet
and then you start from the top and you
say okay so i found this bound
like i found an upper bound and now let
me assume that this
upper bound uh that there's a solution
which is smaller than the which which
produces a lower bound the lower lower
value of
uh then objective function than the
upper bound
and then you get back start and then you
need to go again and try again is there
even smaller one right
this is like the most typical
uh version of course like also for this
optimization
there are unsight answers like core
based approaches where it's the opposite
and they usually are better for really
getting the precise um
lower bound for for this uh but in
practice for really huge instances this
is infeasible and you're kind of then
a try usually going from the top to the
bottom
like from sort of set starts out then
maybe then it's getting too hard and
you're giving up then you're happy with
a preliminary optimal value
just to understand this interface if so
in principle suppose you were doing
exact
model counting so counting the number of
satisfying assignments then you could
also use this interface by saying
okay thanks for the solution and you add
a clause ruling it out
yes exactly yes this is like this is
called blocking um
yeah this is another example here this
is called clocking clause
which is really bad for for the
following reason because if you add this
blocking clause you cannot remove it
anymore
like if you only go through this
interface you have to keep on
like adding these classes and there's
like millions of these classes for
instance you have millions of solutions
and if you're getting in the range of 10
million 100 million solutions then this
completely breaks down
so that's why this is a simple way of
enumerating all solutions or counting
but it's like not something which works
in practice
it's a good exercise for a thought
solving class by the way
to have the students exactly use this
interface to enumerate all solutions
and of course like we're doing we let
the students do this manually in our
logic course
okay okay then
then i continue uh or more questions on
on encodings or this
api
then maybe we could just add also the
comment from the chat that
uh some advertising for mark vane also
says that if you go to github.com
textbooks there is apparently some kind
of
interactive cdc on somewhere and then
carlos
also the gui says it would be helpful to
limit the number of conflicts and manage
un-depth answers from the setzel yes
this is
very like this is in most of my site
solvers anyhow
this is a very important
okay uh then how do i get do you see
this chat too
whenever if i have it on my yes okay
it's in front of the slide all right so
um yeah so i have to apologize so this
webinar interface is slightly different
than the one i'm i'm used to when i
teach
uh so um anyhow here like you all know
this so i just want to make here one
point for the
for the history i wrote here 50s
and and the reason why i wrote here 50s
is because actually
this dp first dp paper was a technical
report which
appeared in 1958 and we
just like a couple of years back we got
hold of that one and
and it's very interesting also maybe
because uh for some of you
are interested in in in algebra and
polynomial reasoning
there's one page on on on ring reasoning
in it
like there's not much in it which didn't
appear
in the um in the journal version which i
found really
interesting anyhow so there's dp and dpl
and i think you all know this is the dp
procedure um
the first time uh for those of you who
are not like that much
into sort of um sad solving
i want to point out these two things
like this the same symbol here
empty right and when i first learned
about this
this everything from youtube actually it
was the most puzzling part for me
but of course nowadays most people are
used to sad service but let me just
reiterate this
this thing so we have two empties like
the formula is empty
right there's nothing left and then it's
true because we have a conjunction of
constraints
or we have um an empty clause and that's
an empty disjunction
and that means if you have an empty
clause then it's it's unsatisfied
okay and then also the dp procedure is
just where you're doing variable
illumination and and just does this um
like by by some kind of um clause
distribution
and you should all uh know how this
works the
um only um and the reason i'm showing
this is also because nowadays
uh this is used in sort of the most
important pre-processing algorithm which
is called uh or which we now call bound
elimination which we we presented in the
satellite papers in 2005
and this one um is really like very
effective
and and very important to do in practice
but i will not talk more about this in
the rest of this talk
if you want to know more about bond
variable elimination we can
uh like do this in the q a session
okay then the dpl procedure is also very
known so this i don't explain
i've shown uh discussed already the the
um
uh the empty thing maybe the only thing
which which
actually i i also find like really
remarkable is
you're picking a literal rate and um
on which you branch on and of course um
if you're really
after satisfiable instances like then
you need to pick the right face actually
which variable you pick is completely
irrelevant
because you're just need to pick the
right face so set the variable to true
and false
and and there are of course maybe uh not
not that
uh important for the proof complexity uh
people but it's like
clear there's lots of applications where
you don't care about unsat like
typically examples are test case
generation and
this comes in multiple flavors like a
symbolic execution where you run a
program and you want to sort of
get all or get some of a good good
fraction of the
branches of your of your program and and
if a branch is not
um coverable that's the same as if sort
of the solver runs out of time so you
just want to usually actually get
into all these different um code paths
and produce values to the input such
that you can reach them
and therefore
from in many practical applications the
choice of the value here either true or
false is the most important part not all
of course but that's
for for practical matters then
dpl example and i'll i'll uh don't say
much about that
one thing uh but i think like this is
clear in this community but
i want to repeat it these smt servers
which are used in many places so so
maybe um you haven't seen that
because i i i'm actually um byron cook
twittered um
a very uh in his tweet he had a link to
um
to a two hours video of the cto of
amazon
and this was uh pretty amazing because
he was talking about verification but
even more amazing
was that for 20 minutes he talked about
smt servers
and how they use smt servers at amazon
and i thought like this is very
remarkable that you have a cto of one of
the largest companies
uh in the world talking about smt
solving of course i used this
part of the video and showed it to to
the students in our
our course however and that's the
important part is these smt solvers here
they really rely on the cdcl paradigm
which
of course i also don't have to tell
people here in this audience is
different than dpl
and that's why in the the original day
people said
came up with this dplt paradigm which
actually was a cdcl paradigm and i think
this is
important to set this this right
uh okay and then learning clauses has no
goods um
and keeping them and then the notion of
an implication graph and unique
implication point this was what
uh schwa and karem uh actually
um did there in in in the mid 90s and
this was a big
big step forward of course
okay so i'll don't explain it again i
had this in my video too
and and just also like very fast so
here's again the this this sort of
implication graph i also show in the
video so if you're
if you look at this for instance then it
means like here's this literal
t which is assigned to true or viable t
assigned to true and it has these three
incoming edges so that's why it
corresponds to this clause here
right and then the conflict here that's
just the binary clause which says y
and z cannot be true at the same time
which is this one
okay and this is how you build sort of
this implication graph
and then uh you do resolutions in this
implication graph
by by uh actually going backwards kind
of topologically from the conflict
towards
decisions so here like for instance y
was here in the conflict as kind of a
source
um or antecedent and now it's at the
destination or consequence
and and this means like if you look here
carefully that these two
are actually of opposite phase and it
turns out that because all these
literals here are uh are true except um
yeah
uh that they can be resolved so actually
these clauses you see
down here um the the sorry the conflict
clause here
this one is false and then the the
reason for this why this antecedent
is is a forcing reason for the variable
which you can resolve
on this y here and the rest is also
false so if i do this resolution i get a
new clause
which well this this only thing this
single true literal is gone and
and and i have again um a false uh all
false clause left
okay and then you kind of imagine how
you continue doing this so this
corresponds to a cut that's what i also
wanted to say
and i get a new clause and then i can
continue by resolving with this t
right degrees in here which i discussed
before this blue one
and um right so this is the reason for t
the left one
and then i can resolve this with my
prelim my previous service
resolvent and then i get the one here at
the bottom
and this corresponds to another cut so
is the yellow thing is a cut which
separates the decisions from the
the conflict okay and i do it once more
now with this binary clause which says
x implies a z rate and
nothing remarkable happens here um
now something uh interesting happens and
and the
the what's interesting here is that um
i resolve here this this x here right
with with its recent clause here
and the site a literal here of this
recent clause here is already in the
other resolve and we call this a
self-substantial resolution why
self-subsuming
because if you resolve it then this
thing here the other literals in that
clause
except for the resolution literals are
already in the
the other clause with which you resolve
and therefore that
the resolvent here is a subset of of
this clause and subsumes it so in
principle if you have such a situation
you could just sort of eliminate it's
the same as eliminating this not
x from from the from the course and that
has
is guaranteed to happen in cdcl
uh because um if you just resolve away
everything here on the lowest level or
the highest decision level down here
at one point um you need to reach um
the decision here r and that's of course
um
um uh only one literal then from from
decision level and then if you resolve
all of them all of them are gone right
and but the conflict is guaranteed to
have two literals from the decision
level so at one point
you need to kind of shrink and resolve
the same literal again
and when this happens on the current
decision level you get to a special
situation what we call or what uh
drawing karen called
the first european call first uip
that means a unique implication point
like for more theoretically inclined uh
people this might you can also call it
articulation point
of the craft here on this lowest level
so it separates the
the lowest level as ignoring these edges
which cross this stitch line
into the disconnected components
and of course there might be multiple
ones so it might like
flow up and down okay but you stop here
at the first one and that's like uh
the clause we would learn which i hope
you have also seen
seen before the thing which might not be
um
in in standard text is the following so
um
okay when i learn this first uip clause
here right so i'll just go backward
until i only have one literal left in
the resolvent from the current decision
level
then this is really the best clause you
want to learn and you see this probably
here with this
what i marked here as back jumping so
this is the level so if i if i have this
clause i'll actually
have all the literals except for this
this thing here for this first erp
literal here
um not s here um on decision level
uh two actually or uh one
and therefore um as i did in the video
uh you see that these
these levels in this clause are kind of
skipping that
decision level three and that's very
good because now you can back jump to
this level
if you would um um resolve
uh this uh s here right the last
remaining literal
on this this first you appeal to on this
on this uh
last decision level then you'll you'll
get to the decision but you also pull in
this decision level so you pull in the
decision level three
and that's not good because now you can
only backtrack here
to by one level
and also this implication graphs gives
you that for free so that's why we
should go
actually use this first you first erp
clause we we discussed before
okay so this is just again a rehearsal
of what i said in the video so one thing
what i want to show you is minimization
that that i
i skipped in the video
um so if you look at that uh first erp
class it's this this one here um
and at this situation you see that this
bind this this i
here is implied by a binary clause so h
implies i rate so h
implies i and again i have this
self-substituting resolution right
but now on a higher level right not
sorry on a lower level decision level
so not here on this highest decision
level and therefore i can
actually replace if all the literals
which are beside the eye are already in
the clause like in this case it's only h
i can just drop this i from the clause i
drop this i
from the clause and i get a shorter one
the one which corresponds to this yellow
cut
okay and this seems already pretty cool
so but you can actually
do this also recursively what we just
saw was
called local minimization where you
really assume that
all the other literals in the in
the recent clause of a literal which is
in the clause are also in the clause
then you can remove that literal
this is not true for age you see like h
has
g in in in its uh reason as antecedent
rate
but it also has e and e is not in the
clause right
so like the argument doesn't apply right
you cannot remove h
however if you now do a craft search and
you follow sort of backward
the h here you see that actually it
either hits a unit clause which of
course you can ignore
or it hits another literal which is
already in the clause
so that's why i can also remove this h
and
um yeah you can of course also see this
is
as a resolution and this idea is due to
nicholas silvansen so on
i was his opponent and this part of the
slides are actually from his opponent's
talk
back then which which i had to give and
then we actually wrote a paper
afterwards because he didn't have this
in his
thesis all right so this will be then
the
the first uip class and you see the the
it has exactly the same decision levels
and uh it has a subset of the the the
literals as the
originally learned clause first erp
clause and that's why it's it's clearly
better
um i don't think like there is a formal
proof for that but
but at least like we're uh
like our empirical um evidence says yeah
so this is
uh always uh the best class to learn
other questions on this because
otherwise i would actually
be tempted to show you uh some code on
this
two questions from me so the first thing
do you always want to have a sub clause
or would you will be willing to trade
like
you know if i maybe if i do some
minimization i can get you just uh
one literal on decision level one
instead of five but it will be a
different one
okay so so last one this gets too
complicated no
actually last year there was a paper by
a student from frahim bachus uh
now i'm mixing up his two students so i
forgot which of the two
sorry if this if you you're in the
audience uh but but like one of the two
um
had a paper which also um actually
uh then was uh making
some of the larger numbers largest
number of instances actually in the
planning track of the sub competition
and the basic idea is was um kind of
revisiting something which
partially was already there in the in
the old days like in the 90s
like slightly modified so it's called
all uips so you would what you could do
is
on each decision level to figure out is
there a literal which implies all the
literals which are in that clause
okay uh the the bad so there's like one
important um
um um one important sort of like
um condition you still want to to meet
and the condition is that when you kind
of find such a
it's kind of a dominator right a
dominator which dominates all the
literals which are in the
in these long claws in that certain uh
decision level then
um it would be good if this domination
would not pull in more decisions from
other
uh levels which you actually did not um
pull in yet like like you see this s
here pulls in this decision level three
and and i also repeated this experiment
so i have a version of keysight which
which reimplements their ideas and it's
really true that
you this seems to be like the the heart
condition
it's actually also very cheap to
implement we're working on a paper on
this actually
so you can always do it you get
actually probably um another sort of
like 10
um smaller classes and for certain
benchmarks in particular for these big
planning benchmarks
uh it can make a huge impact right
you're getting like down from 10
literal clauses to the couple right and
uh that's quite
um quite uh impressive without paying
for it at in other benchmarks so so i
think this is
something one should have now on top of
this minimization in every cd cells over
but
like uh you need to stay tuned for the
paper
before you hear more about that
so just the check that the paper you're
referring to
are made
sorry are you still there
yes i am still there uh just a
close size reduction with all uips yes
exactly yes by nick fang and fajimbakis
and now another question is is do all
solders would you always do recursive
close minimization
or or is it like or is it sometimes too
expensive or you always do
you always do um it's actually pretty
cheap if you implement it correctly and
that's why i want to show that
what what i want to why i want to show
the code
because it's actually actually
arithmetically quite quite interesting
and actually done included ideas and
ellen van gelder hit in here it's not
like uh something you get right in the
the first time and there are many
arithmetic ideas which
which go in there it's not deep but but
it's interesting so i want to show that
code if you're if you want to
what about that or are there more
questions
i cannot keep this [ __ ] open that's the
interesting
mariah has a question
hi yeah thank you
i was wondering if we learn
only the assertion clause
how will a self-subsuming resolution
help us because um if we learn
only the assumption clause we do not
keep the intermediate
the intermediate resolvence anyway so
the fact that
one sub predecessor won't make a big
difference am i missing something
thank you now that like this
self-subsuming resolution comes up in
many places that's why i mentioned it
like the
uh the here like there's it's the
argument why at the end you're
guaranteed to find this first uip
because as i said right at one point you
will need to do a self-submission
resolution because otherwise you cannot
get rid of this uh
like because you have two literals on
the current decision level as you see in
this picture right z and y
and at one point like when you do
resolutions you will need we need to end
up with one
and then then this is like at this point
you find the first erp clause
if you do it in the right topological
order of course
and um this is one reason then
there's the same principle relies behind
this
self-substantial resolution and i think
constantino river cohen
actually came up with exactly the same
idea in the context of in stage
instantiation based
in skin chemical loss rate i think he
calls it global subsumption but it's
exactly the same same idea
and the third occurrence of this thing
is
in something which is called on-the-fly
self-substantial resolution
and this is very related what you just
said actually while you do these
resolutions here
you can kind of you see like we never
did this
in the in in the solver actually this is
implemented as a craft search by marking
literals as you will see in the code
right and but you could of course keep
these resolvents like you may be here
this one is the
the longest one even though it's a
minimization and if you would have this
resolvence you could check
uh whether you were in a case of
subsubstitution resolution
but you would be most interested in if
this happens on this side right on the
an antecedent side if this resolvent
would be smaller than the antecedent
that means you can strengthen this
this antecedent and that happens in
practice actually quite frequently
and it's very cool when this came out so
like two independent groups invented
this
independently i think in 2009
and um and it helps you kind of budget
just do cdcl search to remove literals
in learned clauses or in original
clauses just on the fly this is really
cool
and it it it uses exactly the same
principle
and yo chung hang which was the student
of fabio so menchie is she
she actually um also used this for
pre-processing where you can do the same
trick so you do
sort of uh by elimination and you figure
out that the resolvent is shorter than
one of the two
antecedents you get um
you get um like a self-submission
resolution even more
uh you don't need to really represent
this resolve and you just need a counter
which counts
sort of how many resolvents um how many
literals are still left on the current
decision level
and then you of course have the number
of literals which are in the
in the in the class which uses
antecedents
and if this uh counter then is smaller
than the
then the size of the clause which is
just resolved then you know for sure
that this triggers so it's a very cheap
technique
which is um yeah quite amazing that it
that's possible
um yeah and that's implemented in
keysight but it's not in category
because it breaks a couple of
invariances and if you want i can
elaborate on that but
yeah maybe not because it's getting too
too detailed
i mean there's another question are
there sat solvers which use
processing on the collection of all
binary clauses in the formula
asks victor miller oh yes um
we had like worked on this for many
years actually
um and um so it's um
and also not just us but but i really i
would need to refer to the
um to the handbook chapter so this is
one of the reasons we have
now uh pre-processing chapters because
like in the last 10 years like we looked
at many different ways of doing this
uh and i'm still not over so i have one
technique i'm working on currently which
which people completely forgot and
also maybe you're you you you're not
aware that since 2013 we have these sad
syllables which do in processing in the
winning the competition and they have
been using actually one of the
techniques we invented we called
unhiding which also like
is kind of um a very funny technique
which
goes through the binary implication
graph we call it and does a dual does a
randomized search on this binary
implication graph and this way
gets kind of a tree and then this tree
sample from the
dag of binary implication can be used to
do in constant time
removal of literals while you pass over
the whole formula
and this scales to millions of of
classes
and um yeah there's a paper uh we at
cpir
2013 where we describe it but but the
whole history we
finally wrote up a half a year ago in
this
pre-processing chapter which which i
recommend to
well it's like there's like a whole
section on all these papers on binary
classes
and and like people these things have
been reinvented and there's things which
go back
until the 80s so it's a very interesting
topic since we're halfway through the
the online part of the tutorial there's
a suggestion to have a short
break if it would work with the flow of
the lecture at some point
yeah sure so how does the breaking work
i stopped sharing and then
so should we have like a five minute
break now
so it's less than have a five minute
break and reconvene
in in five minutes from now all right
um
foreign
so i guess we should start in a minute
or so
okay should i start screening again i
guess
yeah why not going to my watch there's
like one minute left of the break or so
so did you elaborate armin on what was
the big jump with with the
the 20 20 winner of the set competition
yes so the secret technique yeah so it's
it's actually related language is
another paper we have to write so let me
where's my slide set here
um
no i can't move this time like all right
so let's go back
where is the pack no the
uh actually there are two solvers which
can you see my mouse pointers which
would be
around here one is crypto minisot and
one is a maple version with the cca and
r
all these top solvers and also category
by the way so like my old version of
category is also around here
they use local search and one particular
actually strange way of doing local
search
and i'm not sure like whether uh karem
is still here so we had like a fight
on this term local search in this
context but we finally figured out
uh that how to do um really um
kind of local search for for the cdcl
servers
which apparently is very simple so i had
this idea uh two years ago
it works as follows so you're you kind
of i call it target facing there was a
post talk
this summer last summer which
works by um kind of looking at the trail
and
thinking about like what would be
actually the best way to achieve
satisf satisfiability and this actually
was motivated by thinking about
um laura's and schill's approach
for kind of fixing this issue right so
they saw that
in in satisfiable instances sometimes so
that the sober makes progress increases
the number of
of of assignments on the trail and
without sort of
right really going upwards and then you
should not restart
and and this is a good observation but
like the the real thing you should do is
actually
you should use this as a as a metric for
optimizing the assignment right
so so what the category does and also
these other two solvers and also
keysight is
to optimize uh the um
to sort of always hit the face of those
of those
sorry always assign the literals
decision literals
to that phase which maximize the trail
in the past and trying to get a larger
trade
and then you can also combine this with
local search
that's what uh give gave this huge chump
and they're actually not just keysight
the other two
or also like like a bigger step than in
the previous years
does it change but so it works better on
satisfiable instances or does it also it
also works
interesting enough also on unsatisfiable
instances it's a very tricky thing
because nowadays all the silver since
2016 this was a big jump in 2016 there
was
also a good jump this was the
combination and i would say
of um chances o idea for using um
this uh stable and unfocused phases
which i call now
uh to together with this reason pumping
of the maple silver and that gave
sorry what's this yes this is this gave
a really a big jump
and um now when you split this over in
two phases one focusing more on
satisfiable one more on onset you can be
more
more aggressive on the unsight because
you don't lose in the satisfiable right
so he would only have sort of like sort
of one engine which does always the same
and it's like mediocre in both uh that's
bad right so better it's to sort of
switch
an increment increasing schedule from um
um sort of stable to focused mode and
then this way you're
kind of be more aggressive in both parts
like for the stable mode you're
more aggressive for the satisfiable
instances and the the uncertain mode you
may oppress before the unsatisfiable
that's of course like also in keystone
now
this insight is is is put to the extreme
right so
restarting every every conflict for
instance in the in the focused mode
like almost like in this proof
complexity papers right
all right should we i guess we're
officially back from the break and have
already started so yes please continue
all right so i want to show you uh well
first want to go to the
so once again so for those who didn't
watch the videos this thing was uh
written by me just for this um a seminar
like i started like 10 10 days ago and
i did something similar in 2012 like
that was the time when you saw the
picture with donald knude back then it
was called cleanling
but that one was i would say like the
first option of making it clear
and uh yeah so so it's like um
a sat solver currently no pre-processing
in it but like a decent like
sort of cbc-l only server and for
instance just
like one and a half ah no two hours ago
i added like
a proof checking to it so you can now
spit out proofs and what i want to show
you
uh um there's another right another idea
i had and that's why i actually put
more work into this and this is related
to also to transects o point um
john zigg oh had took minisat and added
all his uh
um all this idea like this multi tire
and this table and and focus what i call
it now
to um as patches
on on the web right uh but i had the
idea why uh
wouldn't it be better to have a solo
which actually does all of these
patches kind of as a configuration
okay so for instance uh you can now uh
do um no re no
no learn right
and this comes with completely switches
of learning in this server
and and the point is that there's
nothing else nothing left from learning
so it's completely clear
that you didn't do anything sort of um
by just sort of like wasting sort of
code or
cycles which was related to
to um to learning and now if you for
instance then
ask uh uh the south such silver and you
you run it on a scene f um which is um
cnx plural sorry cnf's um then
it it takes like 1935 conflicts
if you uh do the default version
you're getting 127 conflicts and
actually for this bigger uh regression
tests
uh which um there's this thing probably
you can't see this so i need to move
that
uh like for for 16 uh the
uh the the version without learning um
already um is is getting uh much slower
like ten thousand conflict while the
other one had
um has uh way smaller
now the the downside of that is you need
to get these um
that's over of course correct right so
for all these different combinations so
so once again so
so the thing i currently implemented is
uh
uh no blocking literals so i didn't talk
about those yet here but like in the
video
then there's like compact data structure
which completely removes binary classes
you can disable learning uh which of
course will also is
disable the next one so there's implicit
uh relation if you disable learning you
will not also not do
a database reduction you can disable
restarts completely take all the code
out for restarting
then this is something special for
variable move to front which
which i fear i will not have time to
finish until our time's up
and then this is the stable and focused
mode i was talking about right
and there's another like low level
optimization
um now um there's like also um
and in order to test this i i
implemented the pairwise tester which
tests like all these um
uh oil combination of pairs of options
and then runs the test suite on this
thing
and um if you run just the test with um
uh as you would usually do you're just
getting so
i have a slow machine here sorry about
that you're just getting
um
a set of regressions running right and
these regressions will of course then be
run for all these different comp
configurations um this has also uh
actually uses a set so inside this this
combinatorical testing for generating
these um
uh like interesting configurations like
all combinations of pairs
but of course you can also and that's
what i usually do if i do a release
like i combine all four versions you
can't imagine how many bugs you actually
find this way right
and this is kind of i think really
needed in order to really claim that you
have sort of removed for instance here
restarting then this low level
optimization no learning and no blocking
literal string
yeah i haven't done minimization i
should do that too i just figure
all right now to this minimization thing
and yes it's supposed to be
documented well this silver and um
maybe i should start to minimize
so here we get the deduced clause and
now we're going to minimize
uh so so apologize this is c for for
several reasons
um but i hope it should be readable c in
the
and those places where i think like the
average non-c
expert might have a problem i i give
explanations like for macros so so maybe
this is also a gentle
uh introduction into this kind of usage
of c but what this thing here is doing
here it's it's really just sort of um
going over the deduce clause this was
our for instance first erp
clause and and tries to remove uh
literals and so it checks for each
literal like the di we had in the
picture right
whether it can be removed and this thing
is now our recursive
function and let's uh just um peek at
that one
okay and basically um
i'm using here um this poison thing
which says
um okay this is an idea by ellen van
gaal who described
paper from 2009 where uh because you
uh this this this function minimize
literal which is recursive it
calls itself here so it's kind of a
depth first search of the implication
graph
and um this function is called from
every literal in the clause right we're
trying
to minimize and therefore if you start
search started that first search from
scratch every time
you have a potential of traversing the
whole implication graph
every time from scratch right so it's
like not
kind of linear in duplication graph
anymore this minimization
however by um adding these two flags
here so in the original mini site code
like there was
only this flag here but adding two more
flags like one is sort of a positive
case yes this literal can be removed and
the other one says no this cannot be
removed in the current implication graph
you're actually guaranteed to have a
linear linear arithmetic for this
minimization
and typically with this you get like
half of the time
of the whole analysis procedure maximum
is spent in minimization well if you
don't do this you might
might uh surpass the like the rest of
the
minimization time and all together
usually it's like around
um like 20 to 30 percent of the whole
running time of the solver is spent in
conflict analysis
and as i said maybe half of the conflict
analysis is due to this
minimization and um now when you do this
all your p shrinking you add maybe uh
the same factor so so the point is this
all your p
shrinking here um it should be um
there's a typo i just received
this uap all your p shrinking is good
enough
so that it gives you so much benefit
that you you can sort of
make analysis time 30 slower
okay but um the interesting thing is um
um i have also the reclassified versions
of this thing but
it turns out that this simple uh
recursive version ucl
i mean it's not that simple but like you
see this here i just go over the
the literals of the recent clause here
and then i try to minimize
each of them uh if i'm hitting the
literal which
which is the current one for which i
have the reason of course i skip
it and uh okay and at one point if i'm
not
able to minimize that literal
recursively this other literal
then i i'll get to the point of marking
things um
like poison okay so if rest is not true
then i'll mark it a poison
okay it's uh interesting that this
recursive version is actually faster
than my
d reclusified version also the the mini
sub code here has
because it only uses scene here has a as
a non
recursive version um yep and
yeah the the only thing uh which makes
it possible and which has to
you have to be careful is of course to
limit the recursion because we're having
huge
instances sometime and yeah so source
c stack size is limited so that's why
you need to put a limit here
this is currently at i think like a 10
000 or so by 10 000
depth in keysight you can actually have
kind of um tail recursive optimization
here for binary clauses right so then
if you want to chase see that check this
keysight code
where like if you go down here and you
figure out this clause
here is actually a binary clause then
you kind of can
jump back here with a loop at the
beginning and that way
it's like you have a really probably the
best way but i don't do this here
okay one thing which is um which might
be so
yes um you mentioned the performance of
satch
is that this is vijay here uh armen
hi herman so the question was uh you
mentioned that it is
the the recursive version performs
pretty well
was that against the sat 2020 benchmark
or
no this is like this this is by the way
in category and keys are the same
so in category and keysight i
experimented with both versions in both
of them i had
because i cannot believe it that this
recursive version on modern hardware is
faster than the
the recursified function which is of
course like
three times as much code right so you
need to yeah this uh
stack handling yourself right but it's
it's really faster so it seems to me
that these processors and
and c compilers are optimized for this
kind of
recursive function it's better to let
sort of the
that's that's my maybe it's also the
branch prediction you have no idea so
it's it's unclear to me but it's true so
i cannot beat the
uh the the recursive function with the
recursified one
and it's simpler right that's the reason
why i
um yeah
and there's this poison idea as i said
this is due to um
uh alan van gelder right and and donald
trump has another idea so this is only
in kisat
which is counting the literals you see
on a certain level and things like that
if you really want to understand this
and that more detail to that uh you
should probably look at the category
code where i also give lots of
comments so here's like the comments are
a little bit tears but
uh you will get more more understanding
there
all right um so otherwise you see this
is it right this is just a recursive
function then they're like the base
cases of course you need to get them in
the right order and things like that so
this means for instance this scene here
means that your your this literal is
actually in the clause but of course
like at recursion depth zero you cannot
do that because you can then always
remove a literal
so you need to guard this scene here by
by
that the depth is larger than one right
then you and
but these these two are are pretty clear
right if you cache before
this literal and it was poisoned then
you're not cannot remove it if it's
removable you don't need to search it
and this way you get a linear algorithm
okay this is what i wanted to say about
this
minimization other questions on that
there is a question in the q a yeah okay
there's a question why
does n block change the reasons
this one yeah this is the latest thing i
did
uh this morning so uh n block
um um okay so um
maybe i should actually go to the place
where this is explained in the code so
just for you also maybe to see
that i really make an effort to make
this understandable right
i should say that's a question by
matthias fleury also
okay then mention the names
probably the one who knows most about
it's it's about this comment okay
in um so so actually
when you uh when you watch the clauses
right so you you need to so i explain
this blocking literals in the video
right and these blocking literals are
kind of kept in the water stack
and uh all right so i'll have
now since i prepared it i could
sorry
i could just draw the water stack so you
see what i mean
right so the water stack would have here
the um
blocking literals and and here the
classes
all right and then uh this is kind of
the
uh say maybe uh of literal minus two the
the the water stack right and uh
and here are the clauses where were um
like there's a minus two because it's
watched but there's maybe also a three
in here
and and the three can be here but it
could also be if this is a four and this
is another clause and
also needs to contain minus two so at
the first or second partition but the
sphere could four could be here it could
be actually
uh here could be five which is um
[Music]
um not the other watch and then these uh
literals here we're going to use for
um like when we traverse this this stack
here
doing propagation we first check whether
these literals are true and if they're
true we don't need to pay this uh so i
like this so that's why i'm doing it
this is the most expensive part in the
sats
so this is actually in in
if you do profile you get 50 to many
more times now with all this
optimization it's not
like 80 anymore but it's still if you
wouldn't do these optimizations you
would spend eighty percent of the time
so without these blocking literals you
spend like eighty percent of the time in
a set server in this point of the
reference
and the reason is because these uh
clauses are completely random in the
memory so the the the the cash is not
big enough
uh okay uh however now and that's the
the thing i want to explain what what if
there's a clause which is only uh
like the minus two and four right so you
would have here
also four and you point to that clause
then you actually don't need this clause
you can completely forget that because
if you know that this is binary so you
mark this as
binary and
all right and the reason is because you
know it's binary you don't need to go
here you only need to check the value of
off
of four and if four is true right you
can ignore it if all is false you found
the conflict
if four is is unassigned you assign for
and you can make this to the extreme so
you that you actually completely um
remove those uh binary clauses and
that's what this thing is about
so now i find don't find my other window
anymore
okay and now if you don't have these
clauses anymore
these binary clauses and you still want
to have your
your your minimization
function uh not change right so this
thing just assumes here
in the recursive call that i i have a
clause right so this reason here is a
clause
and uh but you had you don't have a
clause right
then you need to kind of um sort of
have a kind of a globally allocated
clause somewhere in the server which
always is used for this purpose and just
reach the
these uh this literal and this this
reason which is not the clause but
actually the other literal
and puts that in that clause and then
you can iterate it as if it would be a
real clause that's the argument
i i call them um literal
clauses
okay does this answer the question
matthias
can i can i ask another question if you
don't mind
you mentioned something about
subsumption resolution
right and i missed that discussion for
some reason uh
was the finding that the lot of the
clauses
that are learned by a cdcl sat solver
uh lend themselves to subsumption
resolution is that the finding that it
so happens that
there is a overlapping so i didn't
prepare this but
um so
but the keysight has of course options
for this so let's
let's do um matrix and
um so keysight has this this in right so
i'll just
compile now keystart with this on the
fly subsumption and then let's take
a test case which
oops test
which version should be test kisa test
um tests c and f's and then i take uh
like any one so it's like one in the
regression suite so i'm just not sure
whether it really happens
then i do minus v and then uh so this
takes
um and then i would say uh
somewhere there should be on the fly
strength rate
so in in one percent of the of the
conflicts you get
like on the fly strengthening and
on the fly sub some of them are subsumed
so if the original conflict
and the the first antecedents you're
using
are um
of the same size and the reciting
resolve and is smaller than both of them
then that resulting resolving subsumes
both
and then you strengthen one and you just
assume and you remove the other one
which
is quite amazing because during conflict
analysis
you will actually remove like a
redundant original clause is this way
right and this happened here could be
also a learn course i didn't have that
here
right so and this is a simple test case
so there are test cases where 50
of the conflicts this is happening
actually
the only tropic of this this technique
is that it breaks the same in variances
as like what what chronological
backtracking would break
which is a headache actually in
implementing the silver
but if you have one then implementing
the other is actually
uh easy and um
yeah so so we also have a paper on how
to implement non-ecological backtracking
in that
that also like lends them to this this
thing
okay thank you
okay so so one thing i want to show you
this i'm doing on my
my other machine is like so so i'm happy
if somebody else would would add things
to this and and of course
it would be cool to add um them
uh with the preprocessor so if you do
pedantic compilation
like you will like all the things many
things will break and that's
but this is on purpose so it would be
good to have this pedantic compilation
also try
all right
more questions otherwise i'll where
well actually i have one more question
so it would be cool to
kind of do a study of this subsumption
resolution
with respect to different categories
like do we see more of this
from verification instances versus hard
combinatorial instances
uh yeah known to be hard uh or crypto
instances et cetera like what is the
difference
no i mean like this is one one thing
we're completely missing like like
as i told you this all uip thing from
nick
uh is is really amazingly successful on
this planing
instances it's it's quite traumatic
actually
yeah but on on the other instances you
need to work very
hard to get the sats over
not be worse okay so so what that means
is you have this technique which
seems plausible and then for 80 of the
benchmarks
unless you work very hard you will
actually make the sats level worse
and then maybe if you figure out how to
do it put the right bounce and
everything
then you're getting to sort of like a
stable phase and then you get the
benefit on this like small subset
but before you do this before you invest
the time you would need to know that
there are subsets where
this technique is helpful and and that's
something like people don't do
in the um sat community and we should do
this more i think
because like in many cases where this in
the past there was some interesting new
insight it was always due to that so so
in this case
here you see the i think this was really
triggered by by the comment of
of lahore and chile and laura's in the
audience like
where they had this i think they were
but they called it lazy
something like they stopped restarting
it one if the
if the trail is increasing or something
right
and and so and they saw this effect on a
certain set of instances on crypto
instances actually
and this now after uh you see eight
years or seven years in 2019
i figured that out and now it's like
like it gives a big win so it's i think
like we need to sort of like be a little
bit more modest on
what we want to achieve not right really
sort of always winning in the
competition or like also how we do the
experimental evaluation but like
trying to see these effects so i'm
completely with you yeah
totally thank you
okay
i think like the only thing i wanted to
show you um the second thing beside
besides minimization
is what i wanted to show you
uh today is proofs and for that
i'll i'll just go very fast over the
history
and and i also don't have time to to to
talk about
technical these dates but i'm happy to
to to explain something is some
somebody is is interested so there has
been um
also part of this pre-processing so so
so i have to um
agree that we started this whole thing
in 2010
like with something called block clauses
which nowadays are completely switched
off so until like 2015 i would say they
really gave
an improvement on this servers but but
like for plain
cdcl putting block crosses into
pre-possession does not
give you anything it just slows you down
a little bit
um but this whole line of of research
started with that
thing and in 2010
and then we added lots of other sort of
um uh um
redundancy properties and and then at
the end led to many
many uh cool results in our domain and
i'll highlight some of them so
so mine has this really huge proofs
and and also related to this is of
course this work on
certified um certifying the outputs of
of sad source
which is also a big thing
which happened in the last five years
and
again i don't have much time to say
explain that so i just want to give you
a flavor
on this thing and maybe with an example
so
here's the cnf which is the cnf i used
actually in the cdcl
part on this is the the full cdcs
cdc cnf with over three variables it's
unsat and if you run
like picosat an old start solver of mine
on these you get this format
and and uh this thing had like here not
just the original clauses
and you see this because the two zeros
here but otherwise they're just like um
the same and this would be the first
learned clause
and in the in the paper by um
by paul beam and others they call it
proof
change which is kind of hidden here like
this is the the
the clauses you would use to derive that
clause here
and here are the clauses listed in like
the only two so you could actually have
a resolution proof
okay um and this was called the extended
proof
format back then ellen van gelder
earlier proposed we should really use
resolution
uh traces where these guys would always
be two right so you have two clauses at
most
which give give give that one and not
this
like a proof change where you have
multiple clauses
which give this one then uh
this didn't work because it was 10 times
larger than than this format which is
also
due to at least the name is due to ellen
van gelder it's called
roop for reverse unit propagation so you
would only list the
the clause and then i say okay this
clause is implied by the cnf and then
you add the clause
to the formula then this clause is
implied by the new cnaf and so on so you
always add like a new clause to cnf
where you check every time that it is
implied and what's implied well it's
like
on this slide it's this box here which
says the formula implies this
clause through unit propagation and the
way you check it with the sats always
you take the negation of this clause and
you propagate
it and then if this leads to a conflict
then you say it's unit propagated
okay and and this is much more compact
than this one here
however it uh slows down the solving
quadratically because you never
you sort of the solver here keeps on
throwing away classes so like
maybe i should show you this um
later and and therefore the learning um
accumulates more and more classes and
and this over throws them away uh quite
aggressively actually
um i i remember laura made this comment
also once
like 95 of the clauses in the typical
runner
are really not are thrown away all the
time kind of garbage collected
and therefore the this should be also
done by the proof checker because it
it's otherwise getting too too slow and
then mariah had this idea
why don't we just add those clauses
which are deleted
into the proof trace so this trace with
the d here
has exactly the same meaning as that one
except that you're
throwing awake losses so f gets smaller
and of course like
if you're only interested in your
foundations you can drop clauses anytime
you just need to make sure
if you drop these two clauses in order
to derive this clause
you cannot use these two clauses anymore
and this then leads to proof checking
which is really
um almost in the same order as the the
original uh
proof generation and i want to show you
this
with a demo so that you get a flavor of
that one that's what i
hacked like two hours ago and so uh
oops cnfs
so um this is our um
of course like now you can do this with
with all the different
um but let me do it with the standard
configuration
all right so this is four thousand six
hundred uh conflicts
and uh and uh yeah so like
uh and it had actually six reductions so
for those of you who watched the video
these reductions are these
minuses here so and and and all together
it had like four thousand conflicts but
at the end only three thousands remain
uh this will become much more dramatic
for longer runs but typically
uh it's um it means that for instance
this will always be
uh almost will be not much different in
since we have glucose it will be this
could be a square root of
of this number it's still kind of not
sort of logarithmic or something but
um you throw quite a away
clauses quite aggressively
okay and now we can dump this proof here
to to stand it out
the second argument as you probably saw
by maybe i should say
sorry the second argument here is the
the proof where you want to start a
proof and of course if you give it
uh like a temp proof then then uh you
have this
proof here okay what do you do with this
one well you can
check it so you take a a proof checker
like a trot trim
and then it says verified or you you
take i have another one
and there are many ones now uh which
which do this and you can
do this but um you can also just look at
the proof
and this is the ascii version so in the
competition
there's a binary version but that's not
useful for for us here
and so what i want to show you here are
these d lines so these d
lines are just the places where such a
reduction takes place and you throw away
clauses
so these are properly now satisfied
clauses because you usually would not
throw away binary clauses but of course
if they're satisfied
then you you throw them away and these
other lines here these are clauses which
were learned right
uh and so on right so so you also see a
little bit like what the cd cell silver
does right so there's like a
long clause now and uh yeah there are
instances where it is getting
really long so this is of course a small
because it's part of my regression suite
if you do it on real uh problems it will
be small now we can
have these okay and then at the end of
course you you get the empty clause
right so there's like a unit learned
another unit learned
and at the end we find the empty class
right and at this point the proof
checker checks
that all the clauses before without
those d
clauses just by unit propagation give
you a conflict
okay so this is the most important part
which i want to show in case you haven't
seen that so that's why i want to take
like questions for this one because if
you haven't seen this practical proof
that might be
interesting so so you're wanting to say
are you that this group uh
proof format uh is more compact than
a complete resolution trace right
and uh it also start enable other
research and
newer proof systems exactly this is what
would be the rest of the talk which i
don't have time
but exactly but the the
the um there's like one thing also like
this is not the end here also from a
practical point now we have a d
rat and actually turns out that now
we go back a little bit again because
this thing where you have the extended
trace is way faster to to check right
and so actually the l red which is kind
of this thing combined with these
is sort of what you probably want in
applications
where you keep the chains which makes it
harder for the set server to produce
them
currently what's what's done is uh like
thread trim like the tool we saw
would take this clock this proof and
then produce something like that
automatically and then they don't need
to to to trust stratform because he can
later check
this proof the reason you call it
rup reverse unit propagation is is it
because you do a
when you produce these clauses you do a
unit propagation and um negated and unit
propagating derived false is that why i
mean
okay yeah yeah so so there's lots of
different names for this one this
rook is due to ellen van gelder we
called in other papers at for
asymmetric tautology which also has a
long history so again i refer to the
pre-processing chapter where
there will even explain this history and
um yeah so it's kind of
implied clauses by the formula through
unit propagation these are
80s and so this uh what you can think of
a cd cell server is just adding clauses
like that
you always like to find a class which is
implied by the formula through unity
propagation
you just list them this is what this
group format does
and then you need the d in order to
check it fast
there's also some other things which you
might find interesting you find it in
papers
this is actually multiset um for
for for for really making this precise
you want to have a multi
multi-set semantics of these classes
uh also in particular if you want to
merge proofs
with this format so like from going to
here also makes things a little bit more
difficult
but that's not the end as i said so we
probably want to go back and actually do
these extended traces nowadays
and these are also the ones which are
checked by these proof checkers actually
here down down here and
like new all papers
okay so now um
like there's like 11 more minutes
and um i could now of course do a very
brute force
way to the through this all these class
redundancies and it starts as i said
with our
uh 2010 paper with the plot clauses
and it's so the basic idea that you use
plot plus and simplify the formula
is so appealing but at the end it's not
practical anymore
which is very funny but it led to many
other things uh
which i've shown already and and i would
explain here
what this block clause elimination is
but i don't think we should do that now
and and then we went to this right thing
which is already also eight years and
became now the
the standard for for the sub competition
so this is more general and in principle
if you allow new literals even as
powerful as
extended resolution and they have been
interesting papers like uh
two years ago with um and and as i said
like for this whole
history of doing that we got a very nice
uh award
even though from a practical point of
view this original work this block
clause
is is not useful anymore at least
nowadays so
um and yeah benjamin diesel here got a
nice thesis
with lots of um best papers
on this one this was his first paper and
uh yeah one thing i'm particularly proud
of is this thing and we don't know
who actually came up with this but we we
i remember the day when we threw
uh this thing on the blackboard and
it's kind of the most general redundancy
property you want to have
in in um that's what we said back then
uh for for uh for cnf
but it's not true now we found like
an a pre-processing problem
and published a pip on this that is not
completely true anymore
but anyhow so what's also interesting is
that you use a
witness which is a partial satisfying
assignment
to show the redundancy of a clause right
so you're kind of doing some
something strange you're kind of
searching for this omega which is kind
of a sub
check like a mp check to to show
that this clause is redundant which is a
coin p check okay so this is
um explained in detail in this paper and
it
also has this other thing i mentioned
that we found
like also one of the old techniques we
we had in the early days of this whole
discourse thing
is actually not covered by this thing
which was completely amazing to us and
we have a formal proof for that
and it's uh so i think we need new proof
systems and libonic my student and i
are working on this actually because i
think like the
the history this does the story is not
not finished here with these
proof systems which as i said before
when we wrote this thing here on our
whiteboard
in the office there i thought this would
be the last paper on on this redundancy
we're going to write but i don't think
it's true
okay then i have an explanation of this
pr proofs which i don't have time and
then there's like a whole
um like um sort of thirty of these
improved systems yes is it fair is it
fair to say
i'm trying to think of it this
intuitively
and imagine that uh i have a formula
f and then i somehow add a clause
to that formula to get a new formula
except that the clause is not
implied by the formula however i
guarantee that
the original formula and the new formula
equally satisfiable
so therefore the value here is that
imagine now suppose you're trying to
invert a hash function okay a crypto
hash function
so we know that this is usually a hard
problem
but we also know the answer because it's
satisfiable
so we know that there are many
satisfying assignments so it's okay
if i add a clause to the formula such
that
the resultant formula loses some
solutions
as long as i guarantee that at least one
solution is preserved
by doing so if i can do that then
potentially i make the search much
easier
and this could be a very powerful way of
thinking of
how you attack problems that are
otherwise
very hard to attack so here's an example
and maybe this is a good
good thing to to finish this talk so
because i find i find it really amazing
and um so we came up with this pr clause
and also
uh with this um so i we have an
algorithm for that which i
also don't have time to explain but
maybe this this is a good part
to reiterate what we change just said so
what are these pr clauses and it turned
out we came up with this pr course in
the everything i just flashed which i
don't have time to explain
um which uses a subs like an oracle
start solver
as a sub uh routine right but this is a
different story so i just want to
explain this so we had this and we
we actually got even the best paper
award for this thing
and and then of course like they were
yours asked uh
yeah have you tried this on the
competition instances right that's what
what you would have asked to and then we
said
um yes we tried and out of these uh 500
instances
from that competition only four were
solved okay
not like four more no only for the
software
but those four were not sold by anything
else and this
is an instance of this problem here
which is called the mutilated
chessboard this was submitted to the
competition
um um by the forgot the name and uh
it's a it's an encoding of the phone
problem you take a chess board and you
remove the two corners here and then you
try to cover it with dominoes right
and that's not possible right because
you remove two plaque ones and there's
the invariant that each domino covers
exactly one black and one white
so it's like so i think this has similar
flavors like these setting formulas um
okay now what does tdcl do right so it
would like place these dominoes and then
get in the conflict
and then it would learn a clause and
this is already pretty powerful because
it
removes like a lot of these dominoes
here
and learns only a subset which also
removes lots of other things so
everything which is not covered here on
this right hand side
would you don't care okay but you still
see there's like lots of
like uh scenarios how you would need to
cover to to to fill the whole
like try everything okay now what does
this cd cell do this learns these pr
clauses these stronger clauses well it
would say
okay um if i have for instance here
these two dominoes
you see that this iteration is of course
the same as if i would have these two
dominoes here right
because they cover the same part of the
board
uh and for ternary like three dominoes
you also have the situation
and guess what marijuana analyzed
the city sdcl so which i wrote is called
cytical
the output of it and if he saw these
clauses
sort of automatically generated by the
the silver
uh and by with this insight of course we
were able to sort of hand
manually also craft these clauses and
develop pr
clauses you can prove that they have
this omega alpha thing
and um then just add all of them right
you just do
these are not many right and then give
the resulting formula with these added
to the cdcl so when it solves it in no
time
so i have experiments for this i think
here
and this way we were able to uh really
automatically solve very hard
uh formulas pitch and hold 50 and and
this state in formulas
and these were the five the four
benchmarks which
i told you right the solver just solved
them and
uh yeah well maple was able to solve
some of them but
like it's very hard while this goes um
in almost no time okay so this is maybe
one one in one inside here
all right three more minutes so i'll
i'll have not discuss
these things so karam sakala asked
something that i
was also thinking about i mean it seems
like this example is essentially doing
symmetry breaking
or no or do you know how this
this this is no this is uh redundant
process already this is a way of
infinity breaking so so as as which you
said like this hash function
thing he was saying is a good analogy
another one would be you know in
mathematics you always do this without
loss of generality right
okay and that's exactly what's happening
so this this this
um this alpha you saw before
is applause you kind of learn which is
not implied right
and but you know that if you assume this
alpha now then without loss of
generality
if if if it would without this alphas
would be satisfied it would be also
satisfied with this alpha and you
the witness for this is this omega
and here it's not completely symmetry
breaking because these the the way how
this is encoded
so you kind of have variables which say
domino goes to the right or domino goes
down at this point right
and of course like there is a kind of
symmetry
like semantic symmetry in it but like
the form it's not in this formula
but but the the karma is completely
right so this is a form uh this is goes
into the same direction so it's like a
similar argument uh and uh marijuana is
also um not for these pr clauses but he
has
um like uh
translation of symmetry breaking into
red uh red proof system
so this thing this pr is even stronger
okay then the red
thing and then we proved last year that
it it cannot do covered clauses
so that's why i'm saying this we're not
at the end yet with this whole story
sadly though we might be approaching the
end of the
[Music]
i have to slices talk yes
uh so this is things we didn't talk
about so
um yeah
and this is my personal sad solo history
which is personal right
start solving so i changed the title
into solving because this talk is about
sat solving
and the green party on the right is the
thing where
well i'm hoping to make progress and i'm
also working on
and uh yeah this sub satan smt anywhere
uh so this is the amazing thing about
this tweet and this
is talk by the cto of amazon talking
about
smt silver and explaining what that is
and that they're verifying
their thing this is pretty amazing so
we're you see like certain smt
everywhere is is should always become
pink or blue because it's there right
this is like the sad singularity
sorry the sad singularity
okay so thank you for your attention so
actually a question if you go back one
slide
yeah for the purposes of of
uh this semester now we have a lot of
people theoreticians practitioners
uh hanging out with each other though
sadly only virtually but still
so your favorite pick of you know i
don't know three four five topics what
what do you think we should be thinking
about and talking about
trying to understand from an applied or
from a theoretical point of view
i mean um like you and i have been
discussing about it oops sorry about
this arithmetic reasoning so i'm still
very interested in in this part so this
is like something where
i think we might make a progress and
it's also interesting because it bridges
to
computer algebra and
this is clearly something one should
should have a
closer uh look at um
[Music]
yeah apparel and distributed start
solving so like there's this open
question
um so i'm not sure like whether this is
a proof of complexity another one we had
this in the in our first banff
uh seminar back then there was um ashish
uh sahara had to talk on this maybe also
the wall
on can you understand pearl sat sawing
through look
so this sort of the the proof complexity
thing like or by sort of like
thinking about structures of proof that
would be
really interesting this is also related
to the
uh papers by mariah where you sort of um
where you um where they do use a
different
paradigm this couping conquer paradigm
and not say dcl
on top but then at one point we switched
to cbcl because then
if things become more local we'll we'll
use cdcl
but we do global decisions and then at
one point we leave the go
to the city so the third topic uh back
then in banff actually i had a list of
10 issues to look at and i think not all
of them are
are done yet and some of them are
actually listed here
and and one of them was also this
this issue with this um
is there a kind of a complexity theory
for for satisfiable instances because as
i
yeah you asked this before but the the
real kind of
improvement in the last two years was
due to sort of
focusing on on trying to make um
satisfied instances faster
so three things i gave
any final questions from the audience
before we
exit out into gather time again
okay so there is let's see
how victor miller asks how ha yes this
is an excellent question how have you
come up with the names for your solvers
oh uh satch is easy right
as you want to know what what does the
question really mean
so category is obvious right that's cdcl
in it
and keysat is um sat
and kiss right that's also very simple
but the finished connotation is a little
bit fishy
so anyhow and the last
the last one uh the search is of also
clear like if i
i want to write a sats over from scratch
for this seminar it should be called
satch no
no okay yeah i mean lingalin you know
the story so my
my one of my daughters couldn't
pronounce uh a butterfly in german which
is a really awkward word it's called
schmetterlin
and she used a very sweet one which is
lingering and so i picked the name for
the silver
okay thank you so much armin
it's a fantastic
talk and it's sadly we had too little
time but they're still your your videos
which
we can look at for those of us who have
not looked at them already and
and so with this i think we end uh
today's talk um and
let's see if we can figure out how to
virtually
uh leave the room okay thanks everybody
thanks armin
thank you for having me bye
you